facebook instead of taking it personally
somehow i'm saying facebook is killing
people
do something about misinformation which
means by the transit of property
facebook is killing people
don't take it personally that the
president of the united states is saying
that you're a murderer
instead stop being a murderer so the
game here is to pretend that vaccine
hesitancy is solely the repository of
the right
now here's the problem vaccine hesitancy
is not solely the repository of the
right
as it turns out ac biracial data
hispanics and blacks are the two racial
groups in the united states who are
least likely to get the vaccines
those are also the two racial groups in
america that were least likely to have
voted republican
in the last election cycle okay so that
is not
a convincing case that the only people
in the united states who are not getting
the vaccine are not getting it because
of right wing propaganda
it's also true that a huge number of
people who aren't getting the vaccine or
were
vaccine skeptical or maybe already had
covet and don't want the vaccine and
maybe a lot of those people live in
rural areas because one thing that we
saw with regard to masking actually
throughout the pandemic is that people
undertook as you would expect rational
risk assessment when pandemic numbers
went up in people's areas they started
to mask
when the pandemic numbers went down
people started to unmask
because that again is how people act
when they are confronted with an actual
risk
but the media have an agenda and the
agenda is to suggest that if it were
only if we could only
stop people like trump from talking stop
people
on fox from talking if we could just
stop all of this if we could end
quote-unquote coveted misinformation
well then everybody would get vaxxed
because human beings don't have agency
obviously
all we have to do is give them the right
information from msnbc and cnn and then
they will they will get facts now
this of course ignores a bunch of holes
in this theory
hole number one as i mentioned huge
percentages of population that are not
republican are not getting vast
hole number two in this particular
theory
is the fact that there are a lot of
people who are not getting vast
not because of watching fox news or
because of donald trump but because
they do not trust the authorities and
the reason they don't trust the
authorities is because the authorities
have taken every single position on
coveted as possible to take from the
beginning of this pandemic
dr fauci the great and sainted was
saying don't mask up and then he was
saying oh yeah i lied you should mask up
dr fauci the great and saint was saying
don't open the schools then you say oh
well you can open the schools dr fauci
the great and sainted
was saying that once you get the vaccine
you still need to wear a mask and then
he was saying well you really don't need
to wear a mask anymore and now he's
saying well maybe you do need to wear a
mask
maybe there's a great lack of trust in
our scientific institutions because they
spent all of last summer
saying that if you're protesting
lockdowns then you were going to spread
covet and kill everyone but if you were
out there in the streets working for
george floyd then probably you'd be fine
in other words maybe you lost your
systemic trust because you don't deserve
the systemic trust of the american
people
now again that's not a case against the
vaccine i'm not sure there's anybody on
the right who's pro-vaccine as i
am i've been encouraging people to get
the vaccine since literally the first
day it was available
i couldn't have been more excited to get
the vaccine i got it my wife got it my
parents got it i was pumped about it
i think the vaccine is a medical miracle
i also understand why people don't trust
the people who have been saying this
sort of stuff
but again agenda is the only thing that
matters here so
manufacture a new coveted crisis again
we are not in a position of covered
crisis in the united states the stats do
not bear this out
if there is any sort of crisis in terms
of people who are dying it is
a crisis among people who decided not to
get vaccinated and then are more likely
to die and they're adults and they get
to make those decisions themselves and
as long as they're not overwhelming the
hospital system
then we really don't have a public
policy answer to that
but the public policy answer for
democrats of course is shut down
anyone who says stuff we don't like so
here's mika brzezinski
tearing into trump and his media allies
for vaccine hesitancy this of course is
the predicate to the notion that places
like fox news should be platformed
whether you're talking about david
koresh in waco
or the jonestown mass suicides
or donald trump's lies about kovid
people died and people are
dying and they are dying because donald
trump and his
evil allies on cable news and on social
media and on capitol hill
seems like a very strong word evil until
you understand just how many people
this cult continues to kill
okay uh i have just a question you know
by the way that if donald trump had won
reelection
there it would be democrats who were
engaging in tremendous vaccine hesitancy
you know that's the case correct
right i mean kamal harris and joe biden
were saying they don't trust the process
by which trump developed the vaccine
and then when they entered the white
house then all of a sudden it was
the process is great everything's
fantastic we fixed it
msnbc's dr bedelia says the same thing
it's social media and right-wing tv that
are preventing vaccinations
again there is this is just not the case
people are independent actors in the
united states they have the ability to
make their own decisions
typically it is younger people who are
not getting the vaccines more rural
people who are not getting the vaccines
because they live in more rural areas
low black and hispanic people are not
getting the vaccines at rates that that
really are where they should be
the the kind of one-size-fits-all single
factor analysis tucker carlson says x
therefore people aren't getting the
vaccine ignores the fact that even if
you look at tucker's audience hey tucker
might have four million people a night
watching him
okay a huge percentage of those people
by the way are older and probably vast
but beyond that the the bizarre notion
that widespread vaccine hesitancy is
solely due to tucker carlson
or social media as opposed to all of the
other factors mentioned
including some somewhat rational vaccine
hesitancy
i'm not saying that i agree with people
who are not getting the vaccine
but to pretend that these people are all
dullards who don't understand anything
about how
i mean a lot of the people who are not
getting vaccine are like i already had
cove it wasn't that bad
a lot of people are not getting the
vaccine or like i live in a rural area i
don't have a lot of contact with people
so do i really need the vaccine is that
like super duper irrational and crazy
i'm not sure it's super duper rational i
might mix a different risk assessment
but i also have respect
for other human beings and their ability
to assess risk
but because the left believes that
everyone can be controlled from above
their conclusion is that if people make
a decision different than their decision
it's because they are controlled from
above
therefore if we just stop those people
from controlling people then we will get
our preferred outcome
here is a doctor on msnbc making this
case
what i liked about that that was
released in the surgery general is that
it's really pointing to the fact that
this is everywhere right it is the
social media amplification in cases
where
uh and it is it is you know sometimes it
is uh influencers that are on cable
television
right leading cable televisions but it's
also anytime any one of us
retweets something that without checking
the source we are adding to that
misinformation is out there and i think
it's a whole
it truly is a whole of society approach
okay meanwhile joe biden you'll recall
over the weekend he suggested that
facebook was killing people which was
the
which was the predicate for a
governmental intervention in social
media to shut down dissemination of
information
yesterday he quasi reversed himself he
didn't really he said facebook isn't
killing people it's people on facebook
who are saying bad stuff for killing
people on facebook letting them
which means by the transit of property
facebook is killing people here's joe
biden doing it
i had just read that on the facebook
facebook pointed out that it was pointed
out that facebook
of all the misinformation 60 of the
misinformation
came from 12 individuals that's what the
article said so i was asked that
question about
what do i think is happening facebook
isn't killing people these 12 people are
out there
giving misinformation anyone listening
to it is getting hurt by it
it's killing people it's bad information
okay and facebook allowing that is
killing people right so facebook isn't
killing people but facebook is killing
people
in fact says joe biden facebook
shouldn't take it personally when i say
they're killing people they should just
do a better job of shutting down all the
information i don't like
which may change on a day-by-day basis
but since we run all dissemination of
information from the white house
via our media allies we should club
social media is doing what we want
anyway
my hope is that facebook instead of
taking it personally somehow i'm saying
facebook is killing people that they
would do something about the
misinformation
they owe outrageous misinformation about
the vaccine
that's what i meant don't take it
personally that the president of the
united states is saying that you're a
murderer
instead stopping a murderer says joe
biden you can see the manufactured
crisis here
and again it is a media manufactured
crisis is driving
the sort of change that democrats have
been wanting for a while which is
restrictions on social media
which is crackdowns on people that they
don't particularly like
meanwhile and this is really amazing jen
saki the white house press secretary
so she was asked you know if it would
help stop vaccine hesitancy
would you praise trump more like really
instead of turning this into a partisan
issue
why aren't you out there getting trump
to for example cut a psa
why aren't you out there saying the
trump administration did a wonderful job
with this
and there is a bipartisan agreement that
there's a wonderful vaccine that
everybody should get
wouldn't that be better than you know
being out there and yelling at trump and
being out there yelling at people who
won't take vaccines and telling them
that they're fools and morons
wouldn't that be better and jon saki's
like you know we don't need to do any of
that
it seems to me your end goal isn't to
get more people vaccinated it seems to
me that your end goal is to polarize the
the constituency here
even if the administration doesn't
partner with the former president
would he consider highlighting or
acknowledging in a greater way his role
in creating the vaccines
to assure the rural voters who still
support president trump that are
hesitant to get the vaccine
well i think do you have data to suggest
that that's the issue that's preventing
people from getting vaccinated
we've seen almost every former president
play a role
in putting out a psa making sure people
understood in the country that the
vaccine is safe and effective
we don't believe that requires an
embroidered invitation to be a part of
okay but you could just ask trump to do
it with that would that kill you
i mean the answer is yes because it's
all politics i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the ben shapiro show if you
did go ahead and hit that subscribe
button so you stay up to date with all
our future content